oh
[Musique]
e
il y avait une fois dans le quartier des
gobelins à paris
une vieille sorcière affreusement
vieille et l'aide mais qui aurait bien
voulu passer pour la plus belle fille du
monde
un beau jour en lisant le journal des
sorcières
elle tomba sur le communiqué suivant
mada
vous qui êtes vieille laide vous
deviendrez jeune et jolie et pour cela
manger une petite fille à la sauce
tomate
or il y avait dans ce même quartier une
petite fille qui s'appelait nadia
c'était la fille aînée de papa saïd qui
tenait l'épicerie buvette de la rue
broca
[Musique]
il faut que je mange nadia se dit la
sorcière
un beau jour que la diète est sorti pour
aller chez le volailler une vieille
marchand dollar et à bonjour ma petite
fille tu veux de la viande
ah non madame je viens acheter un poulet
zut pense à la sorcière
le lendemain la sorcière sous déguiser
en marchand de volailles
bonjour petite tu m'achètes un poulet ah
non madame aujourd'hui je veux de la
viande
lui pense à la sorcière le troisième
jour déguisé à nouveau l vander la fois
de la viande et de la volaille dose
journalière qu'est ce que tu peux tu
vois aujourd'hui se vendent ou du boeuf
du mouton du poulet du lapin oui mais
moi je veux du poisson crottes ans à la
sorcière et bien puisque c'est comme ça
demain matin je deviendrai à moi tout
seul toutes les marchands de la rue
mouffetard est en effet le jour suivant
toutes les marchandes
il y en avait exactement 267
nadia vin comme à l'ordinaire s'approcha
sans méfiance d'un élémentaire de
légumes pour acheter cette fois les
haricots verts le marchand de la saisie
par le poignet l'enleva et hop en format
dans le tiroir caisse
mais heureusement nadia avait un petit
frère qui s'appelait bachir
voyant que sa grande soeur mais rentrait
pas bachir se dit c'est sûrement la
sorcière qui l'a prise
il faut que j'aille il a délivré il pris
sa guitare et son furieux goudard en la
voyant arriver les 267 marchande qui
était la sorcière se mirent à crier où
vas-tu comme ça bachir scheer ferma les
yeux et répondit je suis un pauvre
musicien aveugle et je voudrais gagner
quelques sous et chanter une chanson qui
s'appelle nadia où es tu n'at on pas
celle-là chan dans une autre mais j'en
sais pas d'autre alors chante là tout
tout tout bas c'est entendu et bachir se
mit à chanter tout
na bien où est elle répond que j'étends
table car je ne te vois plus
- forme moins fort crièrent les 267
marchande
q nous casse les oreilles
mais bachir continuer de chanter quand
tout à coup une petite voix lui répondit
achir bachir des livres moi ou la
sorcière me tuera en entendant ces mots
bachir ouvrit les yeux et les 267
marchande sauter sur lui en criant c'est
un faux ou aveugle c'est un format bugs
mais agir qui était courageux brandit sa
petite guitare et à soma d'un coup la
marchande la plus proche elle tombe
raide et les 266 autres avec pour la
seconde fois la petite voix lui répondit
bachir bachir des livres moi ou la
sorcière me tuera cette fois il n'y
avait plus de doute la voix venait de
chez la marchande de légumes
il entra dans la boutique et il essayait
d'ouvrir le tiroir caisse
bachir bachir des livres moi ou la
sorcière me tuera il tiroirs était trop
dure et bachir travailler et pendant ce
temps les 267 marchande se réveillait se
garde bien d'ouvrir les yeux
elle restait les yeux fermés et elle
s'approchait en rampant de la boutique
comme bachir épuisés ne savait plus que
faire
il vit passer un grand marin tout jeune
très costaud qui descendait la bonjour
marin peux-tu me porter ce tiroir caisse
jusque chez nous ma soeur est enfermé
dedans
et qu'est ce que j'aurais comme
récompense tu auras l'argent et moi
j'aurai ma soeur d'accord bachir souleva
le tiroir caisse et allait le passé aux
marins quand la marchande de légumes qui
s'était approché la trappe à part à pied
et se mit à glapir hop et danse je te
tiens
bachir perdit l'équilibré et laissa
échapper le tiroir caisse
celui ci qui était très lourd tomba en
plein sur la tête de la marchande et de
ce coup là les 267 marchande sûrs tout
en même temps le crâne fracassé
cette fois la sorcière était morte est
bien morte
sous le choc le tiroir s'ouvrit et
nabias ans elle embrasse à son petit
frère le remercia et tous de retour
nerfs chez leurs parents pendant que le
marin ramassait l'argent de la sorcière
[Musique]
m